uh you've got a number of lbgt charities
and campaigners furious with you over
the decision to accept trans children
from the ban on conversion therapy why
did you decide to do this well i'm i'm
sad about their reaction because these
are good organizations with whom uh i we
have had you know great relations over a
long period of time i'm very proud by
the way of uh everything that i've done
and and uh our party has done uh to to
champion these issues i was one of the
first uh conservatives to call for for
equal marriage conservative government
uh brought it in i think when i became
foreign secretary i i
insisted that the lgbt flag should fly
uh even in over embassies where you know
other parts of the of the world where
they didn't necessarily share our values
so i'm i'm 100 committed to this uh and
we will have a uh a ban on on gay
conversion therapy which to me is
utterly abhorrent
but there is there are complexities and
sensitivities uh when you move from the
area of sexuality to the question of
gender
and
there there are i'm afraid there are
things i think still need uh to be to be
worked out i'm sorry we haven't been
able to uh to reach agreement with uh
with
the organization's concern but that will
in no way diminish our determination uh
to
tackle prejudice wherever we can was
that a hint that you could still end up
banning uh conversion therapy for trans
children or do you think that's off the
table now let me let me let me just say
because this is something that you know
frankly
uh for
people
like me
it wasn't something i i
thought that i would have to consider uh
in in great detail and it's these are
these are novel
concepts and we've got to be we've got
to be clear about that
but i suppose i've just make a few a few
points um i don't think that it's it's
reasonable for
uh
kids to be deemed so-called gillick
competent
to take decisions about
their gender or irreversible treatments
that they may they may uh have i just
don't
i think there should be parental
involvement at the very least that's
first second thing i don't think that uh
biological males should be competing in
female sporting events and you know
maybe
maybe that's a controversial meaning but
i just it just seems to me to be
sensible and uh i also happen to think
that um
women should have spaces which are
whether it's in in in hospitals or
prisons or change rooms or whatever
which are dedicated to to
uh to women
that's as far as my thinking has
developed on this on this issue uh now
if that puts me in conflict with
um
you know some others
then we've got to work it all out that
doesn't mean that i'm not immensely
sympathetic to people who want to
to change gender uh to transition uh and
it's vital that we give people the
maximum possible love and support in in
making those decisions but
they are these are complex issues and i
don't think they can be
solved with
you know
one swift easy piece of of legislation
that they've taken
it takes a lot of thought to get this
right
conversion therapy in all its forms
should be banned
that used to be the government's
position
and they've been flip-flopping on this
over the last few days
they need to stick to their promises
but i can't help feeling that this is
yet more distraction tactics from the
government they know
that what is keeping people awake at
night is the cost of living where they
can pay their bills or not in order to
try and distract from that the
government wants to create an argument
about conversion therapy it's not going
to wash
we can all see what they're up to
today is the day when most people are
worried about these new taxations the
government is imposing on them today